vraiment cette année elle a été
particulière pour toi comme pour
beaucoup de monde puisque tu es devenu
père déjà bon ça c'est magnifique mais
la crise sanitaire a aussi arrêté tous
tes projets toutes les tournées étaient
concertées rencontre avec les fans quand
tu avais appris que ça devait s'arrêter
on soumet qui avait été très ému était
adressée à ton public à amiens en mars
dernier regarde et je travaille comme un
chien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les gens qui sont touchés par sa jeune
histoire est vraiment
c'est c'est très égoïste c'est justement
fait de telle issue d'un frustré mais
peu importe puisque la route sont hyper
ému c'est normal ouais c'est bien en
fait c'est surtout que là à ce moment là
c'était vraiment les débuts
des idées première annulation des jauges
en dessous de 5000 donc mois quasiment
tous mes concerts qu'ils pouvaient pas
se faire puis à un moment on nous dit à
ce moment là on est dit c'est juste une
grippe c'est un peu plus grave qu'une
grippe mais rien de fou donc moi j'étais
confus je me dis mais pourquoi c'est
juste une grippe mais on annule tout
alors je me suis questionnée sur les
réseaux machin j'ai dit mais pourquoi on
annule tout on nous cache un truc je
comprends pas nous on dédramatise la
chose et en même temps elle prend des
mesures sans précédent donc donc c'était
confus il y avait les stades il y avait
encore quarante mille personnes dans les
stades mais nous non enfin il y avait
plein de choses qui étaient confuses et
du coup 1
du coup voilà c'était un concert c'était
mon premier concert après avoir eu mon
fils donc j'avais beaucoup d'émotion je
venais de chanter la chanson pour lui
justement cité la juste avant donc je
venais de pleurer donc juste avant et là
sur scène j'apprends que les concerts
sont annulés
panda h et sur celle ce jour là est donc
là et moi tu sais à quel point vraiment
moi le ce métier je le fais pour là
c'est vraiment mon truc c'est de faire
des grands shows de faire des spectacles
de de faire ce truc là et et et quand on
m'a dit ça y est c c c morts et m'ont
laissée
j'ai pris un gros coup derrière la tête
quoi donc ouais t'as eu une petite un
petit moment où tu t'es dit franchement
quand est-ce que je vais reprendre ça me
manque
tu as eu un moment de moins bien ben
ouais parce qu'en fait le problème c'est
que constamment nous à repousser
l'échéance au lieu de vous dire tout de
suite
moi j'ai été à los angeles après quand
ils ont commencé à fermer toutes les
frontières pour pour être auprès de ma
belle fille et s'est du coup
du coup en fait là bas ils ont annulé
annulé directement tous les événements
de 2020 à syrte où les artistes tout le
monde le sport tout le monde a su
directement de 2005 c'est gratuit pas de
faux espoirs pas de machin donc là tu
voyais d'autres trucs donc moi je voyais
ça je voyais tout oser toi son oubli
avant avril 2021 je dis ouais mais nous
on nous a fait repoussée en juin en juin
puis puis on verra au mois d'août puis
en septembre et donc on se raccroche
gracq roche quand même à l'espoir et au
final donc voilà c'est on a les deux
déception en déception et puis surtout
aussi ce qui était frustrant c'est
c'était un comment le dossier a été
traité pour les intermittents du
spectacle pour le secteur de de la
culture de l'événementiel ou voilà on a
eu un peu l'impression jeudi je dis on
je me plains pas pour moi évidemment je
suis pas le plus à plaindre tous les
sens et paris on a eu un peu le
sentiment d'être la dernière roue du
carrosse d'être un peu voilà le dernier
dossier à traiter comme s'il s'agissait
que des artistes qui ce qui qui qui
étions sur scène alors que un concert
c'est 200 personnes par soir entre
l'ailé les hôtesses qui sont à la
buvette au merchandising qui travaillent
à monter la scène les techniciens sont
lucas sait déjà que c'est ça et donc du
coup voilà c'est pour ça que je
m'énervais un peu tout constamment sur
les réseaux sociaux paris pour défendre
juste ma petite personne évidemment